Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Oh, Mrs. Patmore, have you heard news? The young master's come back from the First World War, and he's had his knackers shut off. Oh, now, Daisy, we'll be having none of that talk. Not when you've got 748 dirty pots to scour before bedtime. Wise words, Mrs. Patmore.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。哦，帕特摩太太，你听到消息了吗？小少爷从第一次世界大战里回来了，结果他的命根子都被炸没了。哦，得了吧，黛西，我们可不兴说这种话。尤其是当你睡前还有 748 个脏盘子要刷的时候。至理名言，帕特摩太太。
Oh, Mr. Carson, I didn't see you there. There'll be no talk of knackers at Downton Abbey. His lordship would not approve. And anyway, young master hasn't had his knackers shot off. He's paralysed below at waste. Not so, Carson. Lady Mary! Cousin Matthew has made a miraculous recovery.
哦，卡森先生，我没看见你。唐顿庄园里可不能谈论命根子这种事。老爷是不会同意的。而且话说回来，小少爷的命根子根本没被炸没。他只是腰部以下瘫痪了。并非如此，卡森。玛丽小姐！表弟马修奇迹般地康复了。
Just in time to propose marriage to me in the Christmas special. That is wonderful news, my lady. And I just hope he doesn't then die so he can stop being on ITV and go to Hollywood. Amen, Carson. But Dominic Sandbrook was, of course, authentic dialogue from Downton Abbey, the ITV smash hit drama that was a huge success all around the world. And it dramatized the world of the Edwardian stately home, didn't it? So upstairs, the Earl of Grantham and his family, including the beautiful Lady Mary, and below stairs with Daisy, the scullery maid who we heard there mrs patmore the myopic cook and carson the um stentorially splendid butler well uh first of all hello everybody secondly
刚好赶在圣诞特辑里向我求婚。真是个好消息，大小姐。我只希望他别紧接着就领盒饭，好让他卸任ITV的角色去好莱坞发展。阿门，卡森。但多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，刚才那段当然是《唐顿庄园》里的原版台词——这部ITV的热门轰动剧集在全世界都取得了巨大成功。它将爱德华时代豪宅的世界搬上了荧幕，不是吗？楼上是格兰瑟姆伯爵和他的家人，包括美丽的玛丽小姐；楼下则有洗碗女工黛西（我们刚才听到了），有近视眼的厨娘帕特摩太太，还有声音洪亮、气度不凡的管家卡森。那么，首先，大家好；其次，
i am so so sorry whether you you like downton abbey or whether you hate it um i hope you're still listening um we will be having stern words the rest is history about that about that corner so tom you're a great downton abbey fan aren't you it started i think in 2010 do you know do you know you're a great fan as well i believe of the historian simon sharma aren't you tom do you know what simon sharma said about downton abbey did he not he said it was a steaming silver terrine of snobbery, servicing the instincts of cultural necrophilia. So he likes it too. Yeah, yeah, clearly. I mean, that's absolutely clear.
真是太对不起了，不管你喜欢《唐顿庄园》还是讨厌它，希望你还在听。对于那个角落，我们将在《The Rest Is History》中进行严厉的批判。那么汤姆，你是个狂热的《唐顿庄园》粉丝，对吧？它好像是 2010 年开播的。你知道吗，我知道你也是个狂热粉丝，我记得你很欣赏历史学家西蒙·沙玛，对吧，汤姆？你知道西蒙·沙玛对《唐顿庄园》是怎么评价的吗？他不是说过吗？他说它就像“一盆热气腾腾的势利眼银汤盆，满足了文化恋尸癖的本能。”所以他也挺喜欢的。对，对，显然如此。我的意思是，这绝对是一目了然的。
I have to confess, I don't want to alienate our listeners, but I'm not a massive admirer of Downton Abbey. I think I may have described it to you in a text as one of the worst things I've ever seen. Yeah, you did. But I mean, the ludicrous plots and the hopeless sentimentality of it, it just ticks all my boxes.
我必须承认，我不想疏远我们的听众，但我并不是《唐顿庄园》的超级崇拜者。我想我可能在短信里向你描述过，这是我看过最糟糕的东西之一。没错，你确实这么说过。但我的意思是，它那些荒谬的剧情和无可救药的情感泛滥，完全切中了我的所有雷点。
However, I am aware that it's not necessarily an accurate portrayal of what life was actually like in an Edwardian stately home. And, Dominic, do we have someone who could perhaps lift the veil on what life was actually like? We do indeed. We do indeed. Because of course, as you said, there's this enduring fascination with the world of the country house, and in particular, the hierarchical ordered Britain by the historian Lucy Lethbridge.
不过，我也知道它未必真实准确地展现了爱德华时代豪宅的真实生活。多米尼克，我们有没有人能揭开真实生活的面纱呢？当然有。我们当然有。因为正如你所说，人们对乡间别墅的世界有着持久的迷恋，尤其是历史学家露西·莱思布里奇笔下那个阶层分明的英国。
And this came out about 10 years ago. I reviewed it at the time. I thought it was wonderful. And we are very honoured, Tom, to have with us on the podcast Lucy Lethbridge herself. Lucy, welcome to The Rest Is History. Thank you for having me. What did you make of Tom's Downton Abbey, may I ask? Well, I sit somewhere between the two of you i was also slightly addicted to it but also deplored the kind of saccharine coating that it had and and the agenda i think that it
这本书大约是 10 年前出版的。我当时写过书评。我觉得它非常棒。汤姆，我们非常荣幸能邀请到露西·莱思布里奇本人来到我们的播客节目。露西，欢迎来到《The Rest Is History》。谢谢邀请我。请问你对汤姆的《唐顿庄园》有什么看法？嗯，我的立场介于你们俩之间。我也稍微有点上瘾，但同时也厌恶它那种糖衣炮弹式的包装，以及我认为它所体现的
embodied which was to um resurrect the idea that the aristocracy were essentially benign and their servants were sort of happily codependent because i don't think really that was very true but it was fun because lucy that idea although it's um julian fellows isn't it who's uh i mean he's very into that kind of idea conservative peer i think he is indeed i mean with a conservative conservative peer and there aren't actually that many of them um the idea that he's drawing on is actually one with quite ancient roots in Britain. The idea that a lord and his servants form a kind of feudal community. And it goes right the way back to Middle Ages and names, titles of servants are like butlers, like footmen. I mean, they go right the way back to
某种政治意图。那种意图就是试图重新树立这样一种观念：贵族本质上是仁慈的，他们的仆人则是某种程度上快乐的共生者。因为我认为这并非事实。但它很有趣，因为露西，这个想法——虽然它是……是朱利安·费罗斯吧？他……我是说他非常热衷于这种想法，一个保守派贵族，我想他的确是的。我的意思是，作为一个保守派的保守派贵族，其实这样的人并不多。他所借鉴的理念，其实在英国有着相当古老的根源。领主和仆人构成了一种封建共同体的观念。这可以一直追溯到中世纪，而且仆人的头衔，比如管家（butler）、男仆（footman），我的意思是，它们一直追溯到
the Middle Ages. Indeed, yes. But the Victorian and Edwardian household is a sort of recasting of what used to be the kind of rather rollicking entourage that you would get in a medieval feudal household right up to the 18th century, which would be mostly men servants, in fact. I mean, there were very few women domestics. Most of your entourage would be men. And I think it's a response to social anxiety and to industrialization. You get this desire to absolutely fix the hierarchy, and you fix it very visibly by having lots of servants in uniforms behind a green bay's door. And it's a very obvious
中世纪。的确，是的。但维多利亚和爱德华时代的家庭，实际上是对中世纪封建家庭中那种颇为喧闹的随从队伍的一种重塑，一直延续到18世纪，当时随从主要都是男性。我的意思是，女性家政仆人非常少。你的随从大部分都是男性。我认为这是对社会焦虑和工业化的一种反应。你会产生一种渴望，要绝对固定住等级制度，并且通过在绿贝斯门后面安排大量穿制服的仆人，把这种等级非常显眼地固定下来。这是一种非常明显的
pantomime of the feudal order. But I think that that appears at a time when there's a lot of anxiety about class. There's a lot of new people stepping into the old estates. There's a lot of new rich, there's a lot of new middle classes. And so this is a necessary, as it were, it's necessary to pretend that these households have the deepest roots, that they're locked into a kind of chivalric ideal. But the actual stately homes, the Downton Abbey equivalents, you do get a sense from your book that servants who are working for these houses, they grow up on the estates, they go and work in the big house, they retire to almshouses. I mean, they are living their lives entirely framed by the great house, aren't they?
封建秩序的滑稽模仿。但我认为，这出现在一个对阶层感到高度焦虑的时期。有大量的新面孔步入古老的庄园，有很多暴发户，有很多新兴中产阶级。因此，这就很有必要——可以说是假装这些家庭有着最深厚的根源，假装它们锁定在某种骑士精神的理想中。但是真正的庄园，也就是《唐顿庄园》的同类，从你的书中确实能感受到，为这些宅邸工作的仆人们，他们在大庄园里长大，去大宅里工作，最后在救济院退休。我的意思是，他们的一生完全是由这座宏伟的宅邸所构成的，对吧？
Yes. And what's interesting about it is that it is both, in a sense, a rather privileged kind of job to have once you've got your feet under the table, as people used to say, you know, about their daughters, to try and get their feet under the table of the big house. You ate better than you had never, ever eaten before. You were fairly looked after. You were fairly comfortable. You would certainly be more comfortable than you'd be at home. But of course, you weren't free. I mean, the rules about followers, for example. I mean, the chances of getting married if you worked in a big house were probably greater than if you worked in a middle class house, because you met more men, because there were male servants in the household and visiting male servants. But still, it was frowned on. And if you did get
是的。有趣的是，从某种意义上说，拥有一份这样的工作其实是一种相当特权的地位。正如人们过去常说的，当他们的女儿们“在豪园里站稳脚跟”时……你吃的比你以往任何时候都要好。你得到了很好的照顾。你相当舒适。你肯定比在家里时要舒适得多。但当然，你并不自由。我的意思是，关于恋爱对象的规矩，比如说。如果你在大宅里工作，结婚的机会可能比你在中产阶级家庭工作时要大，因为你遇到了更多的男人，因为家里有男仆和来访的男仆。但即便如此，这是不被赞许的。如果你真的
married, you'd probably be sacked. So it's like a sort of unmarried priestly caste looking after this inner sanctum of the family. But we're not talking about a niche thing, are we? So to pull the camera right back. So Tom started with his extraordinary Downton Abbey rendition. And that starts, I think, in the aftermath of the sinking of the Titanic, doesn't it? So it's Edwardian. And the Edwardian period is the one, it's the upstairs, downstairs world for older listeners. It's what we regard as the sort of, you know, the high point, I suppose, of the master-servant relationship. And at that point, you say in your book, there are one and a half million servants in Britain,
结婚了，你很可能会被解雇。所以这就像是一个未婚的祭司阶层，守护着这个家族的核心禁地。但我们谈论的并不是一个小众话题，对吧？所以把镜头完全拉远。汤姆以他非凡的《唐顿庄园》演绎开场，而这开始于泰坦尼克号沉没之后不久，对吧？所以那是爱德华时代。对于年长的听众来说，爱德华时代就是那个楼上楼下的世界。我们认为这是主仆关系的巅峰时期。而在那个时期，正如你在书中指出的那样，英国有 150 万仆人，
which is the single largest occupational group. There are more servants than there are anything else. That's an extraordinary fact. I think that's women, isn't it? It's for women, occupational group, certainly. I've got a stat here because I copied this out. In 1900, domestic service was the single largest occupation in Edwardian Britain. Of the four million women in the British workforce, a million and a half worked as servants.
这是单一最大的职业群体。仆人的数量比其他任何职业都要多。这是一个惊人的事实。我想那是女性，对吧？对于女性来说，这绝对是最大的职业群体。我这里有个统计数据，因为我抄下来了。1900年，家政服务是爱德华时代英国单一最大的职业。在英国 400 万女性劳动力中，有 150 万人从事家政服务。
But of course, by the time the Edwardian, the sort of acme, as Dominic was saying, the sort of acme of what we see as the kind of the great estates, the great country house, servanted households, they were already on the decline. They'd sort of peaked and they were struggling to hold on. And having servants and having very ostentatious servants was part of a way in which you showed that you were hanging on because already women were beginning not to want to go into service because they had so many other choices. The job opportunities were expanding for women. Well, you see that even in Downton Abbey, don't you think, Tom? Right from the beginning, it's a world embattled by change. Yes. But the detail in your book at the beginning, which you open with,
但当然，到了爱德华时代——正如多米尼克所说，我们所看到的宏大庄园、庞大乡间别墅和仆人群体的巅峰时期——它们其实已经在走下坡路了。它们已经达到了顶峰，正艰难维系。拥有仆人、拥有非常招摇的仆人，是你表明自己还在苦苦支撑的一种方式，因为当时女性已经开始不想去当女佣了，因为她们有太多的其他选择。女性的就业机会正在扩大。嗯，你在《唐顿庄园》里也能看到这一点，对吧，汤姆？从一开始，这就是一个被变化围困的世界。是的。但你书开头部分的细节，
is the idea that actually the superfluity, if you're very, very wealthy, if you're very, very entitled, is the entire point. And there are so, you know, no one ever says, we've got too many servants. They just kind of invent strange titles for them. And you have the brilliant details of the incapacity of even kind of brilliant men like Lord Curzon to cope with the lack of servants. There was lots of stories of, you know, people, you know, log, someone needs a log on the fire, and they're sitting right next to it and their foot is an inch away from the log basket but they still ring a footman to come and do it for them do you remember the story of lord curzon there were many stories told about lord curzon
也就是这样一个观点：事实上，如果你非常非常富有，如果你享有极高的特权，这种奢侈浪费本身就是重点。从来没有人说过“我们的仆人太多了”。他们只是为仆人发明各种奇怪的头衔。书中有着精彩的细节，甚至连像库尔松勋爵这样才华横溢的人都无法应对缺乏仆人的局面。有许多关于人们的故事……比如，有人需要一根壁炉里的木柴，他们就坐在旁边，脚离木柴筐只有一英寸，但他们还是会摇铃叫一个男仆来帮他们做这件事。你还记得库尔松勋爵的故事吗？关于库尔松勋爵有很多故事，
but uh he was you know as you know supposed to be tremendously clever but he was staying in a country house and the servants had gone to bed and he couldn't open his bedroom window. He didn't know how to open the bedroom window. So he simply picked up a log and smashed it. But that's a bit like, we did a podcast about the life of the young Winston Churchill. Of course, he grows up and comes of age in this, exactly this era. And Churchill famously said, he couldn't cook and he said, I can boil an egg. I've seen it done. But nobody couldn't. and he said i can boil an egg i've seen it done but but there's a but nobody couldn't and there's a bit we describe him after the second world war so it's late we're talking about the 1950s and he's sitting disconsolately on his bed because he doesn't know how to get dressed yes that's right he's just so used to other people dressing him um i and i think that
但他……正如你所知，他本该聪明绝顶，但他当时住在乡间别墅里，仆人们已经上床睡觉了，而他却打不开卧室的窗户。他不知道怎么打开卧室的窗户。于是他干脆随手拿起一根木柴把它砸碎了。但这有点像，我们做过一期关于年轻温斯顿·丘吉尔生平的播客。当然，他正是在这个时代长大并成年的。丘吉尔有一句名言，说他不会做饭，他说：“我会煮鸡蛋，我见过别人做。”但没人不会……
lack of practical skills becomes a sort of hallmark of the gentleman, of course, as well, doesn't it? Is that you are someone who doesn't soil your hands with anything useful. And the servants, of course, the more servants you had, the more that you develop this cult of labor intensiveness. So labor intensive things had value. And it's only when wealthy or middle class people have to work themselves, have to do the stuff themselves after the Second World War, that the idea of convenience and mod cons and so on actually becomes something desirable. Because what I hadn't appreciated, and I learned from your book, was that throughout the late Victorian Edwardian period and after the First World War, of course,
他说：“我会煮鸡蛋，我见过别人做。”但……但有一个……但没人不会。我们还描述过他在二战之后的一个片段——时间比较晚了，我们谈论的是 20世纪50年代，他沮丧地坐在床上，因为他不知道该怎么穿衣服。是的，没错，他太习惯于别人帮他穿衣服了。我猜，
labor-saving devices are being invented and are being used in America on the continent of Europe. But in Britain, it becomes an absolute badge of honor that the servant girls will continue to have to rub their hands absolutely red and raw with all the scrubbing and polishing and everything. And that the whole point of the dinner parties is to be as complicated as possible. Oh, yes. And we have that slight cult, which I think still lingers today. You know, the cold house.
这种缺乏实际生活技能的情况，当然也成了绅士的一种标志，不是吗？那就是你是一个双手不沾任何有用泥污的人。而仆人嘛，当然，你拥有的仆人越多，你对劳动密集型事物的崇拜就越深。因此，耗费大量劳力的东西就有了价值。只有当富人或中产阶级在二战后不得不自己动手、自己做这些事情时，“便利性”和“现代家电”等概念才真正成为人们渴望的东西。因为我以前没有意识到，我是从你的书中了解到这一点的：在整个维多利亚时代晚期、爱德华时代以及第一次世界大战之后，
You know, there's something very posh about a cold, uncomfortable house, isn't there? It has an aura of class for us. A distrust of central heating, which is too suburban. Yeah, and shabby, you know. Nothing must look too new. Everything has to look as if it's been around for a very long time and requires a lot of dusting. Yes, and so the point is that it has to be difficult for the servant. So there's this extraordinary detail that George V, of whom Dominic is a big admirer, that he goes around taking photographs of all the rooms in his various palaces so that he can make absolutely sure that after it's been cleaned by the housemaid, everything is put back in place. And if it isn't, there will be all kinds of trouble.
省力设备当然一直在美国和欧洲大陆被发明和使用。但在英国，这却成了一种绝对的荣誉象征：女佣们的手依然必须因为不断的擦洗、抛光和各种家务而变得又红又痛。而且晚宴的全部意义就在于要尽可能地复杂。哦，是的。我们有一种微妙的崇拜，我认为这种崇拜至今仍然挥之不去。你知道，寒冷的房子。
I think that's absolutely reasonable, Tom. It's completely normal behaviour. But I think that is the psychology, isn't it? If you have enormous amounts of money and enormous numbers of people to do things for you, what would generally be a whim or a foible becomes a necessity. So, I mean, you get that with sort of diva celebrities, don't you, who want to bathe in Perrier. This is exactly how Tom behaves when we go on the rest of his history. Like we do live shows, his riders calling for only blue M&Ms. The flowers, the M&Ms.
你知道，寒冷、不舒服的房子有一种非常高档的感觉，不是吗？它对我们来说有一种阶层气场。对中央供暖系统的怀疑，那太市侩了。是的，而且显得寒酸，你知道的。什么都不能看起来太新。每样东西都必须看起来像已经存在了很长时间，并且需要大量的拂尘除尘。是的，所以关键在于，这必须对仆人来说很难。因此有一个非凡的细节：多米尼克的狂热崇拜者乔治五世，会去他的各个宫殿里给所有房间拍照，以便能够绝对确保女佣打扫完后，每样东西都放回了原位。如果不是的话，就会有各种各样的麻烦。
Yes, exactly. So the most common kind of servant is a woman. So I was trying to work out from the figures in your book. I get the sense my maths may be wrong here, but in 1901 or so, there were about 20 women to one male servant. That would be about right, wouldn't it? The male servant would be a butler or a footman. Well, the male servant is generally the preserve of the grander households by this
我认为这完全合情合理，汤姆。这是完全正常的行为。但我想这就是心理所在，不是吗？如果你有巨额的财富和大量的人为你做事，通常只是一时兴起或小怪癖的东西，就会变成一种必需品。所以，你会从那些想用依云矿泉水洗澡的超级巨星身上看到这一点。这完全就是汤姆在我们做《The Rest Is History》巡演时的表现。比如我们办现场演出时，他的后台要求里只有蓝色的M&M豆。鲜花和M&M豆。
time. Over the 19th century, you see this increased feminization of domestic labor. Because in the 18th century, as I say, most servants, apart from people working in dairies and so on, would have been men. And why is that change happening? Well, I think with the Industrial Revolution, I think there's less work on the land for women who would naturally be part of a sort of farming household. And also, I think that there's a slight change in the attitude towards men in service. Men in service becomes like the emasculated figures. They're rather joke figures, the butler, the footman, they're lackeys, they're flunkies, they're supporting a conservative system that is by now
是的，完全正确。所以最常见的仆人类型是女性。所以我试着从你书中的数据中推算一下。我觉得我的数学可能在这里算错了，但在 1901 年左右，大约是每 20 个女仆对一个男仆。大概是这样吧，对吗？男仆通常是管家或贴身男仆。嗯，男仆在这个时候
despised by their fellow working class. but but butlers specifically i mean they are splendidly impressive figures i mean right the way up to the figure of carson in in downton abbey you have the wonderful story of lord haldane who was minister of war at the time being mistaken for a butler and and not feeling embarrassed about this at all because he was such an impressive figure so it was quite a compliment it's actually actually quite flattering. Well, except that there was this very odd thing, which I think you get with butlers, is that, and which Kazuo Ishiguro captures very well in The Remains of the Day, I think, is that they are almost gentlemen, but not quite. And again, you get, I mean, the whole servant and master relationship in this period
通常是更大家族的专属。在整个 19 世纪，你会看到家政劳动的女性化程度不断提高。因为在 18 世纪，正如我所说，除了在乳品厂等地工作的少数人之外，大多数仆人都是男性。为什么会发生这种变化？嗯，我认为随着工业革命的发展，女性在土地上的工作减少了，原本这些女性自然会成为农业家庭的一部分。而且我也认为，人们对待男仆的态度发生了一些变化。男仆变成了某种被阉割的形象。他们成了相当滑稽的丑角，管家、男仆，他们是随从、是走狗，他们在支持一个如今
is about these minutely calibrated vocabulary about class, which really only an initiate can speak. So that to the untutored eye, the butler looks like a gent. But to the people who know that a gentleman would never wear a striped trousers and a dark jacket at the same time, he isn't quite. And his whole, the mode of speaking that's adopted by butlers, which is a kind of weird butlerese. And if you read butlers' memoirs, they all speak in it. You can hardly believe that there isn't some sort of school for them to learn how to speak in this very lugubrious, ponderous way. But it's an affectation of the part of Familius, which is reflected in the servant's hall with the butler carving the roast.
已经被工人阶级同伴所鄙视的保守体制。但是，具体说到管家——我的意思是，他们是气势非凡的人物——一直到《唐顿庄园》里的卡森这个角色，你有一个精彩的故事：当时的战争大臣霍尔丹勋爵被误认为是一个管家，而他对此一点也没有感到尴尬，因为他是如此气势不凡，所以这甚至可以说是一个赞美，其实相当奉承。嗯，除了有一件非常奇怪的事情，我认为你在管家身上也能看到这一点——卡夫·石黑一郎在《长日将尽》中很好地捕捉到了这一点——那就是他们几乎是绅士，但又并非完全是。同样，你也会发现——在这个时期，整个主仆关系
And it's a sort of dim reflection of what's happening in the drawing room, but not quite. And that is caught very well in Downton Abbey, isn't it? The way in which the hierarchy below stairs is at least as stratified as the hierarchy above stairs. And also the fact that these servants often tend to be incredibly conservative themselves well i'm jumping ahead here tom but there's a story in lucy's book in the 1970s about these people who pitch up at blenheim palace the duncans and they get into trouble with the other servants because they have a dinner party and they've invited some of the lower servants still in the 70s that was a fascinating
关乎这种对阶层的微小校准的词汇，只有内行才能说得出口。所以，在不谙世事的眼睛看来，管家看起来像个绅士。但对于那些深知“绅士绝不会同时穿着条纹裤子和深色夹克”的人来说，他又并非完全是。而且他整个人、管家们采用的说话方式——那是一种奇特的“管家腔”。如果你读管家们的回忆录，他们所有人说话都是这个调子。你几乎难以置信，难道他们没有专门的学校来学习如何用这种极其阴郁、沉重的方式说话吗？但这是一种“家仆”的做作姿态，这种姿态也在仆人餐厅里得到反映——管家负责切烤肉。
i i came across jenny duncan um who had been a lady's maid to one of the duchesses of marlborough and she'd married i think the current duke's great-grandfather so he was very old this was in about 1970 and they went with her to blenheim to find this kind of floating galleon of an Edwardian household still existing. I mean, astonishing. Yeah, incredible. And I suppose really the only one that still survives today is Buckingham Palace, where you likewise get that slight sense of hierarchy among the servants. I'm sure. I would imagine so. Well, they have a lot of footmen, don't they?
这有点像是客厅里发生的事情的模糊倒影，但又不太一样。这一点在《唐顿庄园》中被很好地捕捉到了，不是吗？楼下的等级制度至少和楼上的等级制度一样森严。还有这样一个事实：这些仆人往往也倾向于变得极其保守。好吧，我这里有点扯远了汤姆，但露西的书里有一个关于 20 世纪 70 年代的故事，讲的是这些人来到布伦海姆宫，也就是邓肯夫妇，他们与其他仆人发生了矛盾，因为他们举办了一场晚宴，居然还邀请了一些底层的仆人——在 70 年代依然如此，这是一个迷人的
I mean, people don't have footmen anymore, surely. They might have butlers. No, you wouldn't have. I mean, I think, yes, you wouldn't find footmen outside some sort of theatrical. Actually, you'd make a brilliant footman, Tom. I think, you don't think I'd make a good butler? I think I'd be a better butler. I think you're a footman. You're too kind of roundish. No, a butler is quite round. A butler is sturdy. No, a butler's tall tall and granite like footman needs to be over six foot yeah well i can wear heels um so lucy let's talk about the so most of the servants in this period are i was about to say women but actually a lot of them are
故事。我遇到了珍妮·邓肯，她曾是马尔伯勒公爵夫人之一的女佣，她嫁给了——我想是现任公爵的曾祖父——所以他非常老了。那是大约 1970 年左右，他们和她一起去布伦海姆，发现这个爱德华时代家庭的“浮动大帆船”居然还在运转。我的意思是，太惊人了。是的，难以置信。我想，今天唯一依然存在的真的也只有白金汉宫了，你在那里同样能感受到仆人之间那种微妙的等级感。肯定的。我想是的。嗯，他们有很多男仆，不是吗？
i mean they are girls because the average age to start is about 14. Is that right? So that's two years after the statutory school leaving, school age is raised to 12. Yes. Why do you, so you go into service, is it a default or is it a choice by your parents from different options? At 12 or 13, 14, that you wouldn't have had any options really. And then you would, I mean, at that sort of age, you would go in as a tweenie, which is a tiny little maid of all work. And I mean, I did find records of, you know, little girls who were so malnourished that they would collapse under the weight of carrying pails of water up and downstairs and so on. I mean, and they really were children,
我的意思是，现在人们不再有男仆了，当然。他们可能会有管家。不，你不会有的。我的意思是，是的，除了某种戏剧演出之外，你在外面找不到男仆。其实，汤姆，你可以当个出色的男仆。我觉得……你不觉得我能当个好管家吗？我觉得我当管家更好。我觉得你适合当男仆。你有点太圆润了。不，管家也挺圆润的。管家很结实。不，管家身材高大，像花岗岩一样；男仆需要身高超过六英尺。好吧，我可以穿高跟鞋。那么露西，我们来谈谈……所以这个时期的绝大多数仆人是……我刚想说女性，但实际上其中很大一部分是
which again, is part, I think, of that slightly infantilizing thing about when you start in service very early, you are the household, the butler, and by extension, his employers, who you might never even meet, are in loco parentis. Well, you have this terrible you you quote this guy's that there's terrible comments servants like birds must be caught when young yes molded right so they would they they leave their parents you so you've left your parents and then you were working from i mean you were working from what six till ten at night well i constantly well i think um i mean the hours are never set which is one of the reasons why factory work ended up being more popular than
女孩，因为开始做仆人的平均年龄大约是 14 岁。是这样的吗？所以那是在法定义务教育离校年龄提高到 12 岁之后的两年。是的。为什么你……所以去当女佣，这是一种默认选择，还是你父母从各种选项中为你做出的选择？在 12、13、14 岁时，你其实根本没有任何选择。然后你就会……在这个年龄，你会以“杂务小女佣”（tweenie）的身份进去，也就是做各种杂活的小丫头。我的意思是，我确实找到了这样的记录：有些小女孩营养不良，以至于在提着水桶上下楼梯时会虚脱倒下。我的意思是，她们真的还是孩子，
service because of the hours were set but on the whole you were up to light all the fires that was the first job which was pretty backbreaking in a big house, but there would maybe be four of you doing it, but you'd be up at six, yes, lighting the fires, heating the water for the baths and getting the range ready for breakfast. And yes, so you're up in the freezing cold with the dawn and you probably work. Well, you'll probably work until you're told that your work is over i mean that's that's the truth i don't think there were any set hours and that would be after dinner so that would be you'd work you'd work well into the night yes well and certainly if you were a kitchen maid you'd be working the night because you'd have all the washing up to do yeah as as evinced in my brilliant yesition of Downton Abbey, Dominic.
这也再次构成了我所说的关于当仆人时那种稍微婴儿化的事情的一部分：当你很早开始做家政服务时，整个家庭、管家，以及推而广之你的雇主——你甚至可能从未见过他们——都在行使父母的职责（in loco parentis）。嗯，你有一个可怕的……你引述了这个家伙的话，说仆人就像鸟儿一样，必须趁年轻时捕捉，
And is it true that if you saw, so you could go for months, if not years, without laying eyes on the master and mistress of the house, and if you did see them, I mean, obviously you didn't say, so you didn't say, good morning, my lord, good morning, my lady. You sort of withdrew or turned your face to the wall. Is that really true? Well, I think in some houses you were made to turn your face to the wall. At Woburn, they didn't put in electricity. The Duke of Bedford didn't put in electricity until 1930. And one of the reasons he didn't put in electricity is he was so traumatised
然后加以塑造。所以他们离开父母……你离开了父母，然后你开始工作——我的意思是，你从……从早上6点一直工作到晚上10点。嗯，我经常……我的意思是，工作时间从来不固定，这也是为什么工厂工作最终比家政服务更受欢迎的原因之一，因为工厂的工作时间是固定的。但在总体上，你得起床点燃所有的炉火，那是第一项工作，在一个大宅子里这相当累人。不过可能四个人一起干，但你早上6点就得起床，是的，生炉子，烧洗澡水，把炉灶为早餐准备好。是的，所以你在黎明时分的严寒中起床，你可能会工作……嗯，你可能会一直工作到别人告诉你工作结束为止。我的意思是，这就是事实。我认为根本没有什么固定的工作时间，那会是在晚餐之后——所以这意味着，你得一直工作到深夜。是的。而且，如果你是一个厨房女佣，你肯定得熬夜，因为你有一大堆碗碟要洗。是的，正如我在《唐顿庄园》里精彩的演绎所证明的那样，多米尼克。
at the thought of all these workmen who might not realize that they couldn't. They weren't supposed to catch his eye if they encountered him. That's how I feel about the rest of history producers. So so they. Yes. And the Duke of Bedford, I believe, is he the chap who he can't. He believes it common to travel with a bag. So his bags, his suitcase has to travel in its own car, with its own chauffeur and its own footman. That's right.
这是真的吗？如果你看到……所以你可能会几个月甚至几年都见不到房子的男主人和女主人，如果你真的看到他们——显然你不能说话，所以你不能说“早上好，老爷，早上好，夫人”。你得退避或者把脸转向墙壁。这是真的吗？嗯，我认为在某些宅邸里，你确实被迫要把脸转向墙壁。在沃本庄园，他们没有安装电灯。贝德福德公爵直到 1930 年才安装电灯。他没有安装电灯的原因之一是，他一想到那些工人们可能会意识到他们不该这样做，就感到极其创伤。如果偶遇公爵，他们是不应该跟公爵对视的。这就是我对《The Rest Is History》制片人的感觉。所以……是的。而且贝德福德公爵，我相信，他是那个认为……他认为带着旅行包出行是很粗俗的人吗？所以他的行李、手提箱必须坐自己的车，有自己的司机和自己的男仆陪同。没错。
Is that right? That's brilliant. So we've basically been talking about the super rich so far. So I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, perhaps we could talk about what it was like to be a servant to a more middle-class household and then look at the process by which this whole kind of extraordinary Talk about what it was like to be a servant to a more middle class household. And then look at the process by which this whole kind of extraordinary infrastructure just started to collapse and crumble over the course of the 20th century.
是这样吗？太棒了。所以我们刚才基本上都在谈论超级富豪。因此我认为我们现在应该休息一下。等我们回来时，也许我们可以聊聊，为一个更中产阶级的家庭当仆人是什么感觉，然后看看整个这种非凡的基础设施在 20 世纪走向崩塌和瓦解的过程。聊聊为一个更中产阶级的家庭当仆人是什么感觉。然后看看整个这种非凡的基础设施在 20 世纪走向崩塌和瓦解的过程。
So we will be back very soon. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我们很快就会回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们还会拉开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Thank you. My brains are becoming soft by constant contact with the lower classes. I am sick of the timid, spiteful servant mind. That was sworn foe of the rest is history, modernist, novelist,
如果你想要无广告的收听体验、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的资格，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。谢谢。我的大脑由于不断接触下层阶级而变得麻木不仁。我厌倦了那些胆小、恶毒的仆人思维。这是《The Rest Is History》的死敌、现代主义小说家、
and embodiment of evil, Virginia Woolf. And Lucy Lethbridge, the author of Servants. That's not unusual, is it? Because in your book, you quote another modernist writer, Catherine Mansfield, who fires her cook. She says her cook is evil. And when she's fired her cook, her cook agrees with remarkable grace, I have to say, to go. And Mansfield then writes, how blessed. It's dreadful enough to be without servants, but to be with them is far more dreadful.
邪恶的化身，弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫。还有《仆人》一书的作者露西·莱思布里奇。这并不罕见，对吧？因为在你的书中，你引述了另一位现代主义作家凯瑟琳·曼斯菲尔德，她解雇了自己的厨师。她说她的厨师很邪恶。当她解雇了厨师后，厨师以惊人的优雅同意离开，我必须这么说。曼斯菲尔德随后写道：“真是太幸福了。没有仆人已经够可怕的了，但有仆人则要可怕得多。
I cannot forget that dishonest, hateful old creature down in the kitchen. Now she will go and I will throw her bits to the dustman and fumigate her room and start fair again. So actually, here you have two modernist writers, literary intellectuals, and they're talking of their servants with, frankly, unbridled contempt. How common is that? Because there are also people who actually, in a weird way, love their servants, aren't there? Yes. I mean, the servant relationship, like all relationships, is different in every single family or in every household.
我无法忘记厨房里那个不诚实、令人厌恶的老东西。现在她要走了，我要把她的碎屑扔给垃圾工，熏蒸她的房间，然后重新开始。”所以在这里，你实际上有两位现代主义作家、文学知识分子，他们谈论自己的仆人时，坦率地说，充满了无羁的蔑视。这有多普遍？因为也有一些人，以一种奇怪的方式，其实很爱他们的仆人，对吧？是的。我的意思是，仆人关系就像所有关系一样，在每一个家庭或每一个宅邸里都是不同的。
But I think there is this chafing feeling, certainly in Virginia Woolf and Catherine Mansfield, a rather surprising horror above the physicality and the close presence of someone they felt so intellectually awkward with. They don't seem to be able to bridge that gap. Well, they think they're beneath them, don't they? Let's be honest about it. That's what they think. Yes. And they, I think, are sort of almost guilty about it. That's what they think. Yes. And they, I think, are sort of almost guilty about that. You know, they feel they should be bigger than this, but they can't do it because actually, they're just old fashioned snobs. You have a brilliant account of a valet called Charles Dean, who flatly refused on principle to consider a job offer from an ex-editor of the communist
但我认为确实有一种摩擦感，尤其是在弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫和凯瑟琳·曼斯菲尔德身上，一种相当令人惊讶的恐惧，针对的是那些与她们在知识上感到如此格格不入的人的身体感和紧密存在。她们似乎无法弥合这道鸿沟。嗯，她们认为仆人低人一等，不是吗？我们老实说吧。她们就是这么想的。是的。而且她们对此，我想，几乎怀有一种负罪感。她们就是这么想的。是的。而且她们对此，我想，几乎怀有一种负罪感。你知道，她们觉得自己的格局应该更大一些，但她们做不到，因为实际上，她们只是老派的势利眼。书中对一个名叫查尔斯·迪恩的男仆有精彩的记述，他出于原则坚决拒绝了一位共产主义报纸《每日工人报》前主编的工作邀约。
newspaper, The Daily Worker. So the kind of the Moibius strip of social complexities and attitudes there is perfect, that the valet is very conservative, refused to work for an editor of a communist newspaper, and the communist newspaper wants a valet. Yes, and the rather sort of grander socialists, the people who had servants but considered themselves rather left wing, often deplored the conservative politics of their servants, without in any way giving any sort of break to them as servants. You know, they treated them exactly like servants. They were still, you know, downstairs and below stairs.
所以，社会复杂性和态度的“莫比乌斯环”在那里是完美的：男仆非常保守，拒绝为共产主义报纸的主编工作，而共产主义报纸却想要一个男仆。是的，那些相当高大上的社会主义者——那些拥有仆人却认为自己相当左翼的人——经常谴责他们仆人的保守政治倾向，却没有在任何方面给他们的仆人以某种喘息之机。你知道，他们对待他们完全就像对待仆人一样。他们依然是……你知道的，在楼下和下层。
Well, I love the suffragette slogan, my butler votes while I'm talking. That's great, isn't it? But before the break, Tom, you were saying about we should move down the social hierarchy a little bit. So it's not just that middle class people have servants, right? It's also that if you're a foreman in a factory, you might have, I don't know, a cleaner, a laundry woman. Indeed, if you're a particularly grand servant, you will have a servant. So this is woven into all sort of aspects of society,
嗯，我喜欢女权运动者的标语：“我的管家在我说话时投票。”这很棒，不是吗？但在休息之前，汤姆，你提到我们应该稍微往下看看社会等级。所以这不仅仅是中产阶级有仆人，对吧？这也意味着如果你是一个工厂的领班，你可能也会有……我不知道，一个清洁工、一个洗衣女工。事实上，如果你是一个特别显赫的仆人，你也会有自己的仆人。所以这编织进了社会的各个方面，
almost. Is that right? Well, I think it's woven into aspects of society, but it's also woven into the history of women's work, isn't it? So the Roundtree Foundation, one of their commissions on poverty in about 1910, made not having a servant the marker of absolute poverty, and by which they meant that the sort of lowest kind of servant you get might be a child that you'd pay a few pennies to look after your child while you were out working. Yeah. And so again, that kind of amplifies the way in which servants themselves have a hierarchy. That basically, I think you say that both the upper and the working classes agree that the middle classes are awful. And that it's a terrible thing to have to work as a servant for the middle classes. Yes, servants have a surprise.
差不多是这样。是这样吗？嗯，我认为它被编织进了社会的各个方面，但它也被编织进了女性劳动的历史中，不是吗？因此，朗特里基金会关于贫困的委员会之一在 1910 年左右，将“没有仆人”作为绝对贫困的标志。他们指的是，你能雇佣的最低等级的仆人可能只是一个孩子，你付给他几个硬币，在你外出工作时帮你照看孩子。是的。所以这再次放大了仆人自身也存在等级制度这一点。基本上，我想你曾说过，上层阶级和工人阶级都认为中产阶级极其讨厌。而且为中产阶级当仆人是一件很糟糕的事。是的，仆人们有一个惊人的……
Even the really sort of feisty servants who wrote the great memoirs of the 1950s have a surprisingly absolute sense that old money equals virtue. You know, people with old money know how to behave to their servants and therefore to other people. It's new money everyone hates. It's, you know, parvenus and nouveau riche. And servants despise them more than anything else. They don't know about tipping. They don't, you know, they've got bad taste.
甚至那些性格泼辣、写下 20 世纪 50 年代伟大回忆录的仆人们，都有一种令人惊讶的绝对观念：老钱等于美德。你知道，有老钱的人知道如何对待他们的仆人，因此也知道如何对待其他人。每个人恨的都是新钱。你知道的，是暴发户和新富阶层。而仆人们比什么都鄙视他们。他们不懂得给小费，他们……你知道的，他们的品味很糟糕。
So that was a theme in the recent series in The Crown where Muhammad Al-Fayed hires Edward VIII's valet to teach him how to be a gentleman. So it's clearly a theme that isn't entirely dead but could we uh start to look now at the the way in which this whole world starts to decline and i guess that again as downton abbey uh illustrates um the first world war is a great period of crisis isn't it because particularly men are starting to being called away to the front but also women are being called to munitions work to become bus conductresses to become all kinds of things that don't involve scrubbing grates and polishing the front door. Yes, I think the First World War is the first nail in the coffin of this pantomime. But it doesn't really put it to death because, of course,
这正是近期热播剧《王冠》中的一个主题：穆罕默德·法耶德雇佣了爱德华八世的男仆来教他如何成为一个绅士。所以这显然是一个并未完全消亡的主题。但我们能否开始关注一下，这个整个世界开始走向衰落的方式？我想，正如《唐顿庄园》所展示的，第一次世界大战是一个巨大的危机时期，不是吗？因为特别是男人们开始被征召上前线，而且女性也被征召去从事军火工作、当公交车售票员、从事各种不涉及擦炉灶和擦洗前门的各种工作。是的，我认为第一次世界大战是这个滑稽剧棺材上的第一颗钉子。但它并没有真正将其终结，因为当然，
economic depression meant that there was such high unemployment that people had to go back into service but they were no longer going back into service with the same sense that there was a sort of inevitable place in life anymore there were there was a whole new spirit abroad and a lot of the servants um interviews and so on, one reads, talk about with what resentment after 1918, they went back and found that there was no work. They were forced back into service. There's a woman called Jean Rennie, who remembers her mother weeping when she realised that her daughters would have to go back into service in the 1920s in Sunderland. And is that because it seemed the work is
经济大萧条意味着失业率如此之高，以至于人们不得不重新回去当仆人。但他们不再是以那种认为人生中有某种不可避免的既定位子的心态回去了。空气中弥漫着一种全新精神，许多仆人的采访等资料中，人们读到的是他们在 1918 年之后带着何等的不满重操旧业，却发现根本没有工作。他们是被迫重回仆人岗位的。有一个叫让·雷尼的女性，她记得自己的母亲在意识到女儿们在 20 世纪 20 年代的桑德兰不得不回去当女佣时伤心落泪。这究竟是因为这份工作
backbreaking or is it the kind of humiliation of having to wear uniforms and curtsy and bow and scrape and all that kind of thing? I think it's the beginning of the end for the age of deference. I think people no longer felt that their place in life was divinely ordained. You know, those old Victorian servants halls where they'd have a big sign saying, know your place, as if this was a biblical injunction. People no longer felt that. So Lucy, do you know a publication that was very outraged by this? The Daily Mail. It was the Daily Mail. So the Daily Mail, worrying about the servant problem,
太折磨人，还是因为不得不穿制服、行屈膝礼、鞠躬哈腰以及诸如此类事情的那种羞辱感？我认为这是顺从时代走向终结的开始。人们不再觉得他们在生活中的位置是神圣注定的。你知道，那些老旧的维多利亚式仆人餐厅里挂着醒目的大牌子，上面写着“认清你的身份”，仿佛这是一条圣经诫命。人们不再有这种感觉了。所以露西，你知道有一个出版物对此感到极其愤怒吗？《每日邮报》。那是《每日邮报》。所以《每日邮报》对仆人问题感到担忧，
complaining about the stubborn insubordination on the part of welfare scroungers it is almost impossible to get a domestic servant in this town and it is certainly high time this dull business ceased the streets are full of girls dressed to death who frankly say that as long as they are paid to do nothing they will continue just as they are robust opinions forthrightly trenchant trenchant tom trenchant expressed by columnist in the daily mail dominic what do you make of that yeah unheard of i think you know different times tom different times um uh but but talk about well let's talk about different times actually that is what i wanted to talk about because one of the things that your book captures
抱怨福利懒汉们顽固的抗命不从：“在这个小镇上几乎不可能找到一个家政女佣，这件无聊的事情绝对是时候停止了。大街上到处都是打扮得花枝招展的女孩，她们坦率地说，只要付钱让她们什么都不做，她们就会维持现状。”尖锐的观点，直言不讳的锋芒……锋芒，汤姆，锋芒毕露的表达，来自《每日邮报》的专栏作家。多米尼克，你对此作何感想？是的，闻所未闻，我想，时代不同了，汤姆，时代不同了。但谈到……我们其实还是来谈谈“时代不同了”吧，因为这正是我想要讨论的，你书中所捕捉到的一个特点是：
is that this world is never ever static so electricity is coming in the motor car which means you have chauffeurs joining the the menagerie and they are kind of looser and easier and more informal and and and glamorous in a way that previous servants weren't but the people who really fascinated me were aunts. Oh, yes. So in other words, you can get your own lady help, as they are called, in the 1920s. And previously, the image of the lady help, there'd been this sort of dependent, this sort of rather miserable drab who's kind of hanging around with you. And then in the...
这个世界永远都不是一成不变的。因此，电力的引入，汽车的出现——这意味着男主角里加入了司机这个新群体，他们更加随性、轻松、非正式，并带着一种前代仆人不具备的迷人风采。但真正让我着迷的是“姨妈们”。哦，是的。换句话说，在 20 世纪 20 年代，你可以拥有自己的“女帮手”（lady help），正如她们被称为的那样。在此之前，“女帮手”的形象一直是一种依附性的存在，一种有点悲惨、黯淡无光、在你身边晃荡的人。然后到了……
Yeah, in Room with a View. Yeah, exactly. The sort of washed up spinster. But in the 20s it's like that the lady help is brilliant they can do everything they're a wizard this that and the other and this is the the brainchild of one what's her name gertie mclean is it who who creates this agency can you tell us a bit about what that was for well i think that that is this splendid result of the First World War is the releasing of middle-class women and into, as it were, sort of joyous, well, not joyous singledom, but an acceptance of singledom.
对，在《看得见风景的房间》里。对，没错。那种过气的老处女。但在20世纪20年代，这种“女帮工”简直绝了，她们无所不能，就像个魔法师一样，而这就是——怎么称呼来着——格蒂·麦克林（Gertie McLean）的 brainchild（心血结晶），对吧？她创建了这个机构。你能给我们讲讲那是用来做什么的吗？嗯，我认为这可以说是第一次世界大战的一个绝妙成果，它解放了中产阶级女性，让她们进入了一种，怎么说呢，快乐的——好吧，谈不上快乐的独身生活，但至少是接受了独身状态。
Suddenly, you didn't actually need to be completely dependent on your brother or your father or your male cousin if you weren't married. you could actually, you know, set up in a flat on your own and have a job. And of course, in 1928, you can actually vote. So there's a whole change afoot about what it is for women, slightly more educated women, making a living. And with enormous resourcefulness, they said about filling the gaps where working class women were no longer prepared to step in. So you get these kind of niche jobs appearing rather in the way that we have now, like dog walking or flower arranging, or again, helping people with dinner parties, helping women with dinner parties who didn't know quite what was what. So you could get a universal aunt to tell you where to put the napkins.
突然之间，如果你没结婚，你实际上不再需要完全依赖你的兄弟、父亲或男性表亲了。你完全可以，你知道的，自己租个公寓住，然后拥有一份工作。当然，到了1928年，女性实际上拥有了投票权。所以，围绕着女性（特别是受过一点教育的女性）如何谋生，一场全面的变革正在酝酿之中。她们凭借着极大的机智，开始填补那些工人阶级女性不再愿意涉足的空白。于是，你会发现各种小众工作涌现出来，有点像我们现在的遛狗、插花，或者再次强调的，帮人办晚宴，帮那些不太懂门道的女性筹备晚宴。所以你可以请一个“全能阿姨”来告诉你餐巾应该摆在什么位置。
So just one last thing about the universal aunts. So Gertie McLean, who runs the universal aunts company, she keeps notes on the different kind of people she has on offer. And Tom, I was going to give you a few options and see which you would go for. So Mrs. Violet Rumpton, fully informed on circuses, pantomime and Toad of Toad Hall. Any good? Well, wait for it.
关于“全能阿姨”，最后再说一件事。经营“全能阿姨”公司的格蒂·麦克林，她会把自己提供的各类人员信息做成记录。汤姆，我本来想给你几个选项，看看你会选哪一个。比如：维奥莱特·拉姆普顿夫人（Mrs. Violet Rumpton），对马戏团、哑剧以及《蟾蜍府的蟾蜍》了如指掌。怎么样？好吧，先别急。
How about this one? 32-year-old Pansy Trubshaw. She understands cricket and foreign stamps, but not much else. I'm not so interested in foreign stamps, but cricket sounds good. How about this? Elizabeth Pratt Steed. Disciplinarian, firm without being brutal. Can converse on physics, spiritualism, or foreign missions.
这个怎么样？32岁的潘西·特拉布肖（Pansy Trubshaw）。她懂板球和外国邮票，但别的就不太懂了。我对外国邮票没太大兴趣，但板球听起来不错。这个呢？伊丽莎白·普拉特·斯蒂德（Elizabeth Pratt Steed）。严厉的女管教，坚定而不残酷。能畅谈物理学、通灵术或海外传教。
That sounds your dream. I'd go for either. This is one of these two so I'd either go for Phyllis Beckett she knows all about footer and white mice guaranteed not to nag
这听起来像你的梦中情工。这两个我都会考虑。这两个里头我会选……所以我要么选菲利斯·贝克特（Phyllis Beckett），她对足球（footer）和白老鼠无所不知，保证不唠叨，
can slide down banisters at a push or Miss Hyacinth Plumber late 30s a dab hand at snakes and ladders but her necklines
必要时还能顺着楼梯扶手滑下来；要么选风信子·普卢默小姐（Miss Hyacinth Plumber），30多岁，是玩跳棋和蛇梯棋的个中高手，但她的领口
are too low and she might need to be pointed in the direction of a modesty vest by a stern so which one are you going for tom so you could well you could you could hire the two yeah you could hire the one who needs to be told off and i think i'd hire the one who likes about same time for born white mice and the deckline woman i think i'd go lucy do you have any recommendations there oh i think the white mouse person, most definitely. Yes, absolutely.
开得太低，可能需要一个严厉的人提醒她穿一件保守的内搭。汤姆，那你到底选哪一个？所以，其实你完全可以两个都雇。对，你可以雇那个需要被管教的，而我想雇那个喜欢白老鼠和领口开得很低的女士。露西，你在那儿有什么推荐吗？哦，我觉得白老鼠那个人，绝对是首选。是的，绝对没错。
But on this, Lucy, on this theme of highly educated servants who know all kinds of stuff that their employer won't know, probably the archetype of that, I mean, the most famous embodiment of that is actually a man. And that is Jeeves in the P.G. Woodhouse stories. And how the figure of Jeeves, is he, I mean, presumably he's kind of drawing on this kind of tradition, is he? The figure of the manservant, does he have that kind of mystique in the 20s and 30s? Well, I always think that Jeeves is actually a sort of throwback
但在这个话题上，露西，关于这些受过高等教育的仆人——他们懂得各种雇主根本不懂的知识，这种现象的典型代表，也就是最著名的化身其实是个男人。那就是P.G.伍德豪斯（P.G. Wodehouse）小说里的吉夫斯（Jeeves）。吉夫斯这个人物，他——我的意思是，他大概也是借鉴了这种传统吧？男仆这个形象，他在20、30年代也有那种神秘感吗？嗯，我一直认为吉夫斯其实某种程度上是个复古倒退的人物。
in a way. I mean, he has the, there's a demeanor of the butler, but he doesn't have the, well, he has a sort of demeanor of civility, doesn't he? But we know that he is not servile. So actually, he's further back than that. the sort of 16th, 17th century, you know, master, the servant of the idol master, you know, the clever, the clever clog servant. It's like a sort of souped up Sancho Panza. Yeah, exactly. Is that basically what it's saying?
从某种意义上说。我的意思是，他有那种管家的风度，但他又没有那种……好吧，他有一种彬彬有礼的风度，对吧？但我们知道他并不是卑躬屈膝的。所以实际上，他的渊源比那还要早。有点像16世纪、17世纪那种，你知道的，主人和聪明的智囊型仆人。这就像是一个升级版的堂吉诃德的随从桑乔·潘萨。对，完全是这样。这基本上就是它想表达的意思吗？
Yeah. And so I think actually he is oddly, he's oddly an old throwback in kind of Victorian clothes. But on the politics, Jeeves is really conservative. So Bertie is the person who's always experimenting
对。所以我觉得实际上他很奇怪地在穿着维多利亚时期的衣服，复古得有点离奇。但在政治立场上，吉夫斯是个彻头彻尾的保守派。所以伯蒂（Bertie）才是那个总是喜欢尝试
with newfangled things, with fancy vases, with silly new ways of wearing a tie. Badly chosen trousers. And Jeeves always, are you proposing
各种新奇事物的人，比如奇形怪状的花瓶、系领带的愚蠢新方法、挑错的裤子。而吉夫斯总是会说：“您打算
to wear that, sir? You know, Jeeves is kind of, and we'll discuss it here, what's his club called? Is it the Ganey Mead Club? Club, where all the butlers get together and they have a book that they write all the details of their masters. Not the butlers, the valets. They write all the details of their masters in.
穿那个吗，先生？”你知道，吉夫斯就是那种人——我们等会也会讨论到，他的俱乐部叫什么来着？是加尼米德俱乐部（Ganey Mead Club）吗？那个俱乐部里，所有的管家聚在一起，他们有一本账本，上面写满了他们主人的各种细节。不是管家，是贴身男仆。他们把主人的所有细节都写在上面。
So that is true to life, isn't it? Because as you were saying, butlers, manservants, manservants, menservants, I don't know. Anyway, they tend to be positively reactionary sometimes well i think it would be very very difficult to have been not a conservative in service there were a couple of uh interviews i did with people who'd had butlers in the 50s and one of them or actually one who was a butler in the 1950s and 60s and said that he'd been an under butler to a butler who was a socialist and he said it was an agony for him he couldn't get another job because he'd
所以这很符合现实，对吧？因为正如你所说，管家、男仆、男佣——我不知道怎么称呼。总之，有时他们往往表现得相当保守。嗯，我觉得在那个服务行业里，要做到不保守是非常非常困难的。我曾对一些在50年代雇过管家的人进行过几次采访，其中有一个人——或者说，实际上有一个人在1950和1960年代当过管家，他说他曾在一个持社会主义观点的管家手下当过副管家，他说那简直是对他的折磨，他因为
been a butler for so long yeah but he was a socialist sort of raging class war below stairs in this terrible futility there was nothing he could do about it your kip your kippers you have i mean it's hard to do that but you have this also i mean conversely you have this uh account of a trades unionist i think in poplar uh who's married to his his wife had been a parlor maid and she she always votes yeah he's absolutely he's absolutely fury um and lucy just before we we move on to the final collapse and decline, one other source of kind of educated servants also is fascinating the way it shines a light from the outside on the English middle class household. And the stories of discomfort, you know, people who'd come from comfortable, centrally heated Viennese flats and found themselves in ghastly kind of Victorian villas where they didn't even have toasters. You know, people on the continent had had toasters, electric toasters for 30 years, but they were still expected to use toasting forks and miserable, you know, herrings lunch and um and this again this this slight um sort of penny-pinching frugal cultishness this
当了太久的管家而找不到别的工作。对，但他是个社会主义者，在这个悲惨的徒劳中，在楼梯下掀起了一场狂热的阶级斗争，而他对此却无能为力。你的基荷鱼（kippers）……你得吃——我的意思是，这很难做到，但你也有这种——相反地，你也有这样一个工会成员的记录，我想是在波普勒（Poplar），他娶了一位曾当过客厅女佣的妻子，而她总是投票支持保守党。是的，他绝对是怒火中烧。嗯，露西，在我们进入最终的崩溃和衰落之前，还有另一个关于受教育仆人群体的来源也非常迷人，它以一种独特的方式从外部照亮了英国的中产阶级家庭。还有那些关于水土不服的故事，你知道的，那些从舒适、有中央供暖的维也纳公寓来到这里的人，发现自己置身于可怕的维多利亚式别墅中，里面甚至连烤面包机都没有。你知道的，欧洲大陆的人已经使用烤面包机、电烤面包机30年了，但他们在这里仍然被要求使用烤面包叉，吃着悲惨的鲱鱼午餐，还有这种——再次强调——这种轻微的小气、节俭、带有崇拜性质的
delight in eking things out yeah it's quite moving because you've got people who have who'd been they fled germany or austria where they'd you know they as you say they'd had comfortable highly educated very respectable lives and they and they're sort of forced into service. There's one story, a guy, on his first night, he's waiting at table. And his master or whoever says to him, his employer says to him, where did you learn to wait so well? He said, well, I remembered from the days when we used to stay at Grand Hotels how people did it. And you sort of sense how far they've fallen down the ladder, as it were, which must have been, you know, on the one hand, you've escaped a dreadful fate. But on the other, you know, for anybody with a sort of sense of hierarchy, that must have been a terrible comedown. I think it must have been terribly difficult. And they were often, of course, especially the older ones, were really
对物尽其用的痴迷。这其实挺让人动容的，因为这些人——他们曾逃离德国或奥地利，正如你所说，他们在那里曾过着舒适、受过高等教育、非常体面的生活，而他们现在却被迫去做仆人。有个故事说，一个家伙在他在的第一天晚上，正在餐桌旁伺候。他的主人或雇主对他说：“你在哪里学会伺候得这么好的？”他说：“哦，我记起了我们以前住在豪华大酒店时，别人是怎么做的。”你从中可以感受到他们跌落得有多惨，这可以说，一方面，你逃脱了可怕的命运。但另一方面，对于任何有阶级意识的人来说，这一定是个可怕的堕落。我想这一定非常艰难。而且他们中的许多人，当然，尤其是年长的那批人，真的
quite bad at it, especially older men who suddenly found themselves in these positions of service, having been a stockbroker or something, you know, in their 50s. It was very, very hard and very humiliating. And of course, I mean, it wasn't the case with all families. Some families were very kind, notably Quaker families, actually, who really come out of this particular episode very, very well. But the ones who saw themselves as getting, you know, they're getting domestics on the cheap and they never, ever talked to them. They never asked them. You know, they never said, where did you come from? How was it? What's happening? But is that again part of that because i often wonder about that relationship is there a bit of guilt in there do you think or is it just because how could you be
很不擅长这个，特别是那些突然发现自己处于这种服务位置的年长男性，他们之前可能当过股票经纪人或什么的，已经50多岁了。这非常非常艰难，也非常屈辱。当然，我的意思是，并非所有家庭都是如此。有些家庭非常善良，尤其是贵格会家庭，他们在这段特殊的经历中表现得非常非常好。但那些觉得自己占了便宜、用廉价劳动力雇佣家政服务、而且从来、从来不跟他们说话的人——他们从不询问。你知道，他们从不问：“你从哪里来？过得怎么样？发生了什么事？”但这也是因为那个原因吗？因为我经常思考这种关系，这里面是不是有点内疚感？你觉得是这样吗，还是仅仅因为——你怎么能……
i mean maybe i'm just being naive but you would be conscious of the of the weirdness and because you're conscious these people are human beings with inner lives and histories and do you think there are some sort of employers who just preferred to, you know, they wanted the servants to look away, not to meet their eye, because they actually struggled to engage with them as human being to human being because of guilt. Yes, maybe guilt. In a sense, the relationship does have guilt written into it. I think this is, you know, or embarrassment, perhaps, is sort of awkwardness, embarrassment. And so with the Second World War, and then the Labour government that follows the Second World War, all this stuff becomes a cause of, I guess, heightened embarrassment for employers. And so
我的意思是，也许我太天真了，但你会意识到这种关系的诡异之处，因为你意识到这些人是拥有内心生活和历史的人类，你觉得有些雇主只是更愿意——你知道的，他们希望仆人把目光移开，不要和他们对视，因为他们实际上很难以人与人的身份去和他们交往，而这是出于内疚吗？是的，也许是内疚。从某种意义上说，这种关系确实带有内疚的色彩。我认为这就是——或者说，也许是尴尬，一种别扭、尴尬。因此，随着第二次世界大战的爆发，以及随之而来的工党政府，所有这些事情都成了雇主们感到加倍尴尬的根源。所以
the fact that the economy and the new social structure is against them combines with the fact that they feel perhaps that the whole time for this is gone, do you think? I think yes, after the Second World War, it really was the end. And it wasn't the end of people wanting servants. We then had to start recruiting them from abroad, from places like Spain and St Helena and Malta, and places where there was enormous unemployment. But the crucial thing is, it's the end of that assumed relationship of that had for so long been assumed one of birth, you know, one in which you were born to serve and born to rule. And that went.
经济和新的社会结构对他们不利，再加上他们可能觉得这种时代已经彻底过去了，你觉得呢？我想是的，第二次世界大战后，这真的成了终结。但这并不是说人们不再需要仆人了。我们后来不得不开始从国外招募，比如西班牙、圣赫勒拿岛和马耳他那些失业率极高的地方。但最关键的是，那种长期以来被视为理所当然的关系结束了——那种生来就是为了服务、生来就是为了统治的关系。这种关系消失了。
So you made a point in your book that hadn't really struck me before, that in a way, there's a move to replace one kind of service with another because what you have in the 1950s and 60s is the cult of the housewife of the kind of domestic goddess and you quote and i've seen i mean i've seen the sources myself so i've seen how many of these there are the mass observation program which was a sort of uh for those people who don't know it was a sort of a big program where they would get volunteers to write diaries and to answer questionnaires. So to sort of take the temperature of the country, they would get people to send in housewives to send in what they did in the day. And they too are getting up at six o'clock and going to working until 10 or 11.
所以你在书中提出了一个观点，之前并没有真正触动我：某种程度上，人们正在用一种服务取代另一种服务，因为在20世纪50和60年代，你拥有的是家庭主妇的崇拜、那种家政女神的崇拜。你引用了——我也亲眼看过这些资料，所以我知道这类的资料有多少——大众观察计划（Mass Observation Program）。对于那些不知道的人来说，这是一个大型项目，他们会找志愿者写日记、回答问卷。为了解国家的脉搏，他们会让家庭主妇寄信来描述她们一天做了什么。她们也是早上六点起床，一直工作到十点或十十一点。
I mean, now, admittedly, Tom, you can say maybe voluntarily or whatever but they're not but they're they're doing exactly all the jobs that a servant would once have done but what i was going to say was that they are by this stage allowed to use labor-saving devices so i love the detail that the um the vacuum cleaners are given the name of you know classic names of mechanical housemates yeah kind of poly and daisy and things and you and also of, you know, classic names of... They are mechanical housemates, yeah. Kind of Polly and Daisy and things. And also, of course, you have things like dishwashers. And in your book, you have this brilliant photograph of the Duke of Bedford
我的意思是，现在，诚然，汤姆，你可以说也许是自愿的什么的，但她们并不是——她们正在做的，完全就是以前仆人会做的所有工作。但我想说的是，在这个阶段，她们被允许使用省时设备了。所以我特别喜欢这个细节：那些吸尘器被赋予了经典的名字，你知道的，就像机械室友的名字，比如波利（Polly）和黛西（Daisy）之类的。而且你也拥有——经典的命名……它们是机械室友，对吧？就像波利和黛西之类的。当然，你还有洗碗机之类。在你的书中，有一张贝德福德公爵（Duke of Bedford）在
at the Ideal Home exhibition of 1959, unloading a dishwasher. But in reality, the Duke of Bedford would never have been unloading a dishwasher. And in most houses, the man, we know, because we know that right up until the 1980s, men never touched their dishwashers or their washing machines. It was always their housewife who was expected to do it.
1959年理想家园展览会上卸洗碗机的精彩照片。但在现实中，贝德福德公爵是绝对不会去卸洗碗机的。在大多数家庭里，男人——我们知道，因为我们了解直到20世纪80年代，男人们都从不碰他们的洗碗机或洗衣机。人们总是指望他们的家庭主妇来做这些。
So could you argue that one form of domestic service, paid, was replaced by another, unpaid? I think you could. And the problem of domestic labour is written into the history of feminism. I mean, what does one do with it? I think you could. And the problem of domestic labour is written into the history of feminism. I mean, what does one do with it? One does one do, you know, the career woman who has to employ another woman to do her cleaning for her. Yeah. But it's seen as a problem for women rather than men. Yes, it continues to be a problem. I mean, because the number of male cleaners,
所以你是否可以认为，某种形式的有偿家政服务，被另一种无偿的家政服务所取代了？我想你可以这么说。而家政劳动的困境一直贯穿着女性主义的历史。我的意思是，人们该拿它怎么办？我想你可以这么说。而家政劳动的困境一直贯穿着女性主义的历史。我的意思是，人们该拿它怎么办？职业女性不得不雇佣另一个女人来帮她做清洁，该怎么办？对。但人们倾向于把它看作是女性的问题，而不是男性的问题。是的，这依然是一个问题。我的意思是，因为男性清洁工的数量，
the percentage is absolutely minuscule. So it is still women's work. And do you think that's a legacy of the feminization of the servant hierarchies in the Edwardian? Well, I think it probably is. I mean, it's a response to industrialization, and it's the separation of home and work for the first time. So you've got all these men going out to managerial jobs and in offices and bureaucracies and pen pushing. And they come back and the home is therefore entirely a shrine to the nuclear family, embodied by Victoria and Albert themselves. And so, that it is a, and so work has to be pushed
其比例可以说是微乎其微。所以这依然是女性的工作。你认为这是爱德华时代仆人阶层女性化的一种遗产吗？嗯，我想大概是的。我的意思是，这是对工业化的一种反应，也是家庭与工作第一次分离的结果。所以你拥有所有这些出去从事管理工作、在办公室、官僚机构和伏案笔耕的男性。他们回到家，因此家庭完全成了核心家庭的神龛，由维多利亚女王和阿尔伯特亲王本人具体化。所以，这是一个——因此工作不得不被推向
out to the edges. And so that's where you get this whole architecture of upstairs, downstairs, green base doors, basement steps, you know, the idea that domestic work is something that is done, but is never seen. But the weird thing is, I mean, the weird thing is, is that no sooner has this world been escaped than it's starting to be romanticised and sentimentalised. So one of the, we've already mentioned it, Upstairs, Downstairs, one of the biggest drama series of what, the 60s? 70s. 70s.
边缘。于是你就得到了建筑学意义上的那种上下楼层之分、绿包门、地下室台阶，你知道的，那种家政工作是“只做不说”的观念。但诡异的是——我的意思是，诡异的是，这个世界刚刚逃脱，它就开始被浪漫化和感伤化了。所以其中一个——我们已经提到过了，《楼上楼下》（Upstairs, Downstairs），这是什么时期最大的电视剧之一？60年代？70年代。70年代。
70s. So the age of trade unionism and industrial unrest, and everyone is watching on their television sets, this story of an Edwardian household and their servants. On the topic of Upstairs Downstairs, my favourite story came from an unpublished PhD thesis, which had the revelation that in the first series, which started in 1969, the biggest stars by far, who were Angela Badley, who was the cook, and Gordon Jackson, who played the butler, were given the smaller dressing rooms, whereas the actors who played the Bellamy's, who were in the drawing room, were given the plushiest dressing rooms and that seemed to me a kind of really interesting example of how deeply this idea of sort of upstairs downstairs deference has rotted into the national psyche we don't we we're not even we don't even know it's there so at the time we're
70年代。在工会主义和工业动荡的时代，每个人都在电视机前观看这个关于爱德华时代家庭及其仆人的故事。说到《楼上楼下》，我最喜欢的故事来自一个未出版的博士论文，其中透露了一个惊人的事实：在1969年开播的第一季中，绝对最大的明星——饰演厨师的安吉拉·巴德利（Angela Badley）和饰演管家的戈登·杰克逊（Gordon Jackson）——分到的化妆间反而更小，而那些在客厅里扮演贝拉米（Bellamy）一家的演员却分到了最豪华的化妆间。在我看来，这真是一个极有趣的例子，说明这种“楼上楼下的顺从”观念已经多么深入地腐蚀了国民的心理，以至于我们甚至
thinking about because i've written about the 70s obviously there. So at the time, we're thinking about, because I've written about the 70s, obviously, and I think at the time when people wrote about Upstairs, Downstairs, they thought it was a sort of escapism. The initial commentary was this is an escapism from the industrial and economic turbulence of the 70s and our anxieties about this newly individualistic age. And so, of course, we are romanticising and looking backwards. And therefore therefore you know
都意识不到它的存在。所以当时我们正在思考——因为我显然写过关于70年代的著作。所以当时，我们在思考——因为我显然写过关于70年代的著作，我认为在人们撰写关于《楼上楼下的文章时，他们认为这是一种逃避现实。最初的评论是，这是对70年代工业和经济动荡以及我们对这个新个人主义时代的焦虑的一种逃避。因此，当然，我们在浪漫化、在回顾过去。因此
it's a product of of these circumstances but actually when you think about it it's much more deep-seated than that isn't it because then you had the remains of the day which kind of you know rewrote and undermined the romantic image because you it turns out that stevens the butler but but you you also had brideshead revisited well you had Brideshead Revisited so of course which was very very sentimental but then you have as you said at the beginning the massive success of Downton Abbey and those that the recurrence of those things despite attempts to undermine them or to revise them suggests that it's much more deep-seated than just escapism as you say it it speaks to a kind of obsession with hierarchy and with order that must be hardwired into the British soul. I mean, I know listeners who are more
这可以说是这些环境的产物。但实际上，当你仔细想想，它比这要根深蒂固得多，不是吗？因为后来你有了《长日将尽》（The Remains of the Day），它在某种程度上重写并瓦解了那种浪漫的形象，因为你会发现，管家史蒂文斯……但你也有《故园风雨后》（Brideshead Revisited）。好吧，你有了《故园风雨后》，当然，这部作品非常非常感伤；但随后正如你在一开始所说的那样，《唐顿庄园》（Downton Abbey）获得了巨大成功，这些事物的再度出现，尽管有人试图去瓦解或修正它们，却表明它比单纯的逃避现实要根深蒂固得多。正如你所说，它触及了英国人灵魂深处对阶级和秩序的某种执念，这一定是深深植根于英国人灵魂之中的。我的意思是，我知道那些更偏向
left-leaning will probably be despairing at this, but it's true, isn't it, that people do feel a sort of, I don't know what the word is, do they crave a sense of order or a sense of place? I mean, it's something that we've never really had. So maybe it's easy to romanticise it. And do we always imagine that we are in the drawing room? I mean, does anyone look at Downton Abbey and think, I'd be the kitchen maid? Or do they always think I'd be Lady Mary?
左翼的听众可能会对此感到绝望，但这是真的，对吧？人们确实感受到了一种——我不知道该用什么词——他们是否渴望一种秩序感或归属感？我的意思是，这是我们从未真正拥有过的东西。所以也许浪漫化它很容易。难道我们总是想象自己坐在起居室里吗？我的意思是，有没有人看《唐顿庄园》时会想：“我会成为厨房女佣”？还是说他们总是觉得自己会是玛丽小姐（Lady Mary）？
What do you think, Tom? Would you be Lady Mary? I'd absolutely be Lady Mary. No, I don't know about that. No, that riding case. Like Skittles. Yeah, I think, well, given a choice, but obviously
你觉得呢，汤姆？你会是玛丽小姐吗？我绝对会是玛丽小姐。不，我可不这么认为。不，那种骑马的行头……就像九柱戏（Skittles）一样。是的，我想，如果有得选的话，但显然
I would be some undergardener. Because I think, I mean, when I think about your book, the thing that, it was 10 years since I read it, and the thing that always stuck in my mind, it's a tiny detail. I think the the the girl or young woman's name is edith or edna weway or something like that yes yes and she talks about washing the the with carbolic soap washing the stuff with carbolic soap day after day so much
我会是个底层园丁。因为我觉得，每当我想到你的书，有一件事——距离我读它已经过去10年了，但它一直留在我的脑海里，那是一个极小的细节。我想那个女孩或年轻女性的名字叫伊迪丝、埃德娜·韦韦（Edna Weway）还是什么的？对，对。她谈到用石炭酸肥皂洗东西，日复一日地用石炭酸肥皂洗涤，以至于
that basically her hands become bloodied and blistered and and the worst thing then is she can't allow the bigwigs to see her hands because they are you know to to be disfigured would be would be awful and that is what you don't get in Downton Abbey so even Daisy the scullery maid who is the the kind of the tweenie the one who gets down her hands are not red yeah just that sense of backbreaking of toil and no escape i would have said would be the the frightening thing i'm actually very in downtown abbey very rare that you see that the servants any work housework um yeah so so lucy right at the beginning of you but you have this extraordinary detail from a manual for common sense for housemaids that tables and chairs should be to the housemaid objects of deep interest after her own family and the family of her mistress they should claim the next place
基本上她的手变得血迹斑斑、水泡累累，而最糟糕的是，她不能让大人物们看到她的手，因为它们——你知道的，如果留下残疾或变形，那就太糟糕了。而在《唐顿庄园》里你根本看不到这一点。所以，即使是洗碗女佣黛西（Daisy）——那个介于两者之间、需要干粗活的人——她的手也不是红的。是的，那种将人压垮的劳苦却毫无逃路的感觉，我本以为会是令人恐惧的事。实际上，在《唐顿庄园》里，你极其罕见地能看到仆人们做任何家务活……是的。所以，露西，就在你的书的开头，有一个来自女佣常识手册的非凡细节：桌子和椅子对女佣来说，应该是仅次于她自己的家庭和女主人家庭的“深切关注对象”，它们应该在她的情感中占据
in her affections and that's what you're not getting in Downton Abbey because they're all too busy kind of you know disposing of dead Turkish documents and rushing off with valets and things to actually spend the whole time cleaning furniture and also the feeling, I think, and this is why being a servant was, and probably still is, viewed as an identity more than a job. And that's why it was so complicated for so many, is that it demands such complete sacrifice. Even very kindly employers, they were kindly only in the sense that they were kind to you in the sphere in which you were allotted to be. They didn't want you to come out of it and really flourish. So the idea of, I mean, marriage was the only escape for women servants,
第二重要的位置。而在《唐顿庄园》里你根本看不到这一点，因为大家都在忙着处理死去的土耳其人的文件、跟贴身男仆私奔之类的事，根本没时间把整天都花在清理家具上。还有那种感觉——我认为，这也是为什么当仆人过去是、现在可能依然被视为一种“身份”而不仅仅是一份工作的原因，这也是为什么它对那么多人来说如此复杂——因为它要求如此彻底的牺牲。即使是非常善良的雇主，他们的善良也仅限于他们被分配到的那个领域内对你好。他们并不希望你跳出那个圈子去真正绽放。所以，婚姻是女仆们唯一的出路，
and even for some men servants too. Well, again, I mean, in Downton, the Earl of Grantham is very kind to Carson and to his dog. And, you know, there are things of it that it gets right, I think, kind of. Anyway, Lucy, thank you so much. Such a wonderful book, Servants, a Downstairs View of 20th Century Britain. We should also mention your more recent book on tourists which dominic you and i shamelessly plagiarized didn't we for our episodes on holidays well i mean it was an absolutely brilliant book it was one of my um one of my books of last year if you're interested in social history at all um i think you'll love both of these books so lucy thanks so much thank you everyone for listening
甚至对某些男仆来说也是如此。好吧，话说回来，在《唐顿庄园》里，格兰瑟姆伯爵对卡森（Carson）和他的狗非常好。而且，你知道的，它确实在某些地方把握得很对，某种程度上。总之，露西，非常感谢你。这是一本如此精彩的书——《仆人：20世纪英国的楼下视角》。我们还应该提到你最近关于游客的书，多米尼克，你和我厚颜无耻地抄袭了这本书，不是吗？用在了我们的假期特辑里。我的意思是，这绝对是一本绝妙的书。它是我去年的藏书之一——如果你对社会史有一点兴趣的话，我想你会爱这两本书的。所以，露西，非常感谢。谢谢大家收听。
bye- Bye bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告畅听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。精彩的娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前获得现场门票，请前往 theroftheentertainment.com。网址是……本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。